[Music]
you would say that I'm like the coolest
mom right
well is there really such a thing as a
cool mom
[Music]
yeah even if there is it seems that Tia
Mowry's son Cree has his own thoughts
this is too real this is my life
[Music]
the actress shares this family dance
sesh on Instagram calling her two kids
11 year old cree and four-year-old
daughter Cairo her favorite dance
Partners
I think it's fantastic
may not have impressed him much at the
start but by the end mom clearly won him
over
[Music]
it's not the first time that t has tried
to bust a move with her kiddos
[Music]
like when she put cree and Cairo on
camera dude
[Music]
I mean Cairo she is so wonderful
I'm a True Believer in just creating
memories another memory as Tia told
Jennifer Hudson dancing was her and
sister Tamara's introduction to Showbiz
but my parents they were in the they
were in the Army and on base they were
having auditions for this dance group
and my sister and I were like okay yeah
let's go ahead and you know try out we
ended up getting in the group I feel
like that's how I got rid of my like
stage fright is this practice so you
started dancing first first and a lot of
people don't know that I think it's
always important to continue to treat
your children like children because
that's what my parents did yes you are
an actress but where I come from and how
my parents raised us it's about your
integrity and it's about your character
and it's about who you are as a person
and now that tea is a parent herself
she's also focused on letting Cree be a
kid and when are kids not embarrassed by
their mama's dance moves
[Music]
foreign